hello and welcome to this video playing
in visibility from India okay okay
relations should check this line again
yeah it is played so often and it's
absolutely terrible for black but you
have to have to know why and how I mean
I think this is a good one already
someone I'm gonna be okay he have it I
will just be okay I think white is more
or less clearly better here but let's
see night here yeah and then I p5 and
okay reason to be better is an
understatement just win the Queen iam so
muchi cook can move the night as well
[Music]
cannot be bad to take a look
I'm a full/queen up here I think black
really okay and that line is terrible
for like where it is not not as bad as
it turned out to be in the game okay
Alette whole line is this is close too
close to unplayable for black day 6 is
already lost running this one all nights
if one this is using there's absolutely
no way out he has to go here I but after
the Shelby 6 is also over bishop see 797
just doesn't work and the game we lost
the Queen the key ideas of course that
this is not okay okay and now I'm 95 96
93 is pretty convincing I'm threatening
here cancels it should be to the queen
is trapped it's not playable for black
I'm not sure what the relatively best is
now keep forgetting I think Quincy six
maybe or t6 I keep forgetting this but
it is also pretty bad from black so this
this line should really not be played
from black it's a bit of a shame it
would be an interesting line look like
yeah not yeah this is Wendy five is a
benoni all of a sudden kind of
interesting and see form you can go into
the maroc see but we also have stuff
like 26 or queen 85 it's a fairly
interesting line this black opening it
just happens to be bad because of the
capture ok guys thanks for watching